do you have a favorite prank like the
the coup de gras no so many pranks
unbelievable and some of the best ones
were with steve jobs that didn't quite
come off but we we did all the work to
do them
but they got disturbed did you ever
think about adding a prank inside one of
the computers like some kind of you know
easter egg many times i played i even
taught um computers to elementary middle
school kids for eight years i taught
them how to do pranks i taught them even
how to crack passwords of a computer you
know and it was a long process you know
go down and you know
set up a password on your computer
and then go change your password and see
what parts what bytes in memory change
find those and then start changing a b c
d here on the and figure out what the
scheme is and the scheme was just not
even encryption it was just a cipher you
know an a became an n and a b became a
cube
it was that simple so they'd go to
school and
get
just by looking at the code you can find
where you find where it is and then you
find out how to read it and what it what
it is or change it to something you want
sure amazing but i mean a little bit a
little bit of hacking but for good don't
hurt anybody
america if you thought jackass forever
was crazy oh boy do i have a show for
you it's a multimedia comedy show called
the bucket list tour and the stuff i
filmed for this show is way too hot for
jackass like the general anesthesia bike
ride the vasectomy olympics and sky
jacking the footage is so intense we
have full grown men passing out at
almost every city this bus goes to
so if you think you can handle it get
your tickets right now at stevo.com
[Applause]
you